but also you say for example the the
second phase the part that I've been in
tends to be one of the unhappier times
of life and you think about how much
you're worrying about your kids and
whether they'll be okay and all the the
struggles balancing work and family and
stuff and exactly kind of helpful right
you start to see oh it's not just me
it's everyone practically like what you
say if you look there's part of it that
tracks um happiness I studied okay what
are the happiest and how does happiness
change I won't take everybody through
that but you know in the early years and
then you get into the out just out of
University or whatever you're graduating
you know those are very happy years in
the
um that middle that you're referring to
when there's work-life balance and and
you're trying to juggle a lot and you're
trying to be successful and you're
struggling with yourself and you're
struggling with your family and also
there can be times of disenchantment the
mayor marriage isn't going exactly like
you dreamed or the job okay I'm not the
Superstar because life is tough and you
go and you encounter that middle part of
your life and to those things are known
you know that they happen they're
they're they're normal almost and you
expected and also there are principles
for how do you deal with each one of
those better and then you come and then
I watch people have a a difficult
transition from one phase to the next
phase because you know let's say you go
from the second phase and whether we
call it retirement or something and all
of us you know you're you're in a habit
you're addicted am I important do I
matter what is my status all of these
things that people then get and they
just don't yet know what that new phase
is and become comfortable and enjoy that
new face I've mentored a lot of people
who've gone very very successful people
who've gone okay from being successful
to then that new phase and then
understanding how to find Joy because
the happiest phase is really that phase
which really almost comes on typically
around 60 or after 60 it actually
surprisingly ironically is the actually
the happiest phase in all of life from
Enders across cultures typically because
okay you don't have the work life
balance and amen your parents are gone
your children are on their own you have
a freedom you're not trying to prove
yourself and there are on all the joys
of all of those types of Freedom if you
approach it well and so people
understanding these things and
understanding you know principles for
dealing with the really beneficial